Brown!
Oh!
This is spectacular people.
What did we just see?
And how about Brown with the staredown
on Embiid?
Do you think that you have exceeded expectations?
I didn't care about what the expectations was to be honest.
I got boos when I was drafted,
so I probably did see some expectations but,
you know I mean I just
let the chips fall where they may
and here we are now.
So to you, what is your ceiling?
How high is your ceiling?
I don't have a ceiling.
I'm just gonna keep my head down
and keep working and see where it leads me.
So, 28-year-old Jaylen.
How many championships does 28-year-old Jaylen got?
I'm not gonna jinx myself but
what's that, 6 years?
I'm gonna go ahead and say
5 or 6.
I'm gonna say that.
So you winning the championship
every year from here until...
Yeah I don't wanna jinx myself
You already did; you already said it!
And I don't play to lose
so I'm gonna go ahead and say
I'm gonna give it a 5,
you know what I mean?
5 rings by 28?
That's what
I'm gonna go with that, yeah.
How confident are you about winning this year?
Super confident.
People misconstrue confidence and arrogance.
For sure.
You know what I mean?
I'm not being arrogant
and we're gonna have to take the steps
to be the team that we say we wanna be, right?
It's because we got the mindset of a champion
I think that's where it starts.
So when your basketball career is over,
when you're no longer 22...
I have no idea.
What do you want
to be remembered as?
What type of player?
I'll say one thing.
If I'm remembered as just a good basketball player,
I will feel like I didn't do my job.
Now I know one of your nicknames is "Old Man."
How you know that?
'Cause I know that.
Am I right? Yes or no?
(laughs) Uh yeah.
OK, one of your nicknames is "Old Man"
Right.
And it's because,
you know, people seem to think
that you have this wisdom that's just
beyond your years.
So we're gonna put that to the test.
Really?
Yes.
Now, Jaylen is a cryptic tweeter
He kind of sends out quotes and inspirational messages.
So I'm going to read some of those to you.
You're going to tell me what they mean.
how you interpret them,
how they've applied to your life.
OK.
Are you ready?
Don't get me in trouble here.
Tweet;
"A patient man eats ripe fruit"
Patience last year was one of the things that
I struggled with
'cause I want everything now.
So that was one of the quotes that reminded me,
to be patient.
That's the deep meaning behind.
The deep meaning of that one.
Yeah.
"The moon might steal light from the sun
but they never get the 2 confused"
(laughs)
Please explain.
So, uh, imitation is the highest form of flattery, right?
So
the moon steals light from the sun,
but they never get the two confused.
So you just repeated...
He basically
repeated what the tweet was
in his explanation.
I'm gonna break it down "ATL" style for you.
OK, break it down, break it
You can bite my swag all you want,
but you mean,
but I'm still me.
I'm still the sun.